this video will help you understand what
heart failure is please watch the entire
video to learn about heart failure
your heart is a muscular organ that
pumps blood containing the oxygen and
nutrients your body needs
heart failure means that your heart
can't pump enough blood around your body
in some cases heart failure may be
temporary but in most cases some of the
heart damage is permanent
heart failure can affect both sides of
your heart or just one side
your heart may not pump enough blood to
your lungs to pick up enough oxygen your
heart also may not pump enough
oxygen-rich blood out to the rest of
your body
this can cause the body to hold on to
water and let fluid build up in your
body and in your lungs
many health conditions that weakened or
overwork the heart can cause heart
failure
a health condition may keep your heart
from squeezing as hard as it should
health conditions that can cause heart
failure include coronary artery disease
high blood pressure diabetes heart valve
problems and heart muscle problems that
are present at birth or caused by
infection or toxins sometimes heart
failure doesn't cause any symptoms
especially if it isn't severe but it
often causes these common symptoms
feeling out of breath with a small
amount of activity feeling out of breath
when trying to lie flat waking up in the
middle of the night feeling very short
of breath feeling tired a lot and having
swelling especially in the legs belly
and blood vessels of the neck be sure to
tell your health care provider right
away if symptoms get worse
your provider will ask you to weigh
yourself every day and watch for sudden
weight gain which can be a sign of
worsening heart failure
to find out if heart failure is causing
your symptoms your healthcare provider
may do certain tests
you might need an electrocardiogram
which is a test that looks at your
heart's electrical rhythm
you may also have an echocardiogram this
is a test that uses sound waves to see
how well your heart works a chest x-ray
can show if your heart is enlarged or if
there is fluid in your lungs
sometimes blood tests can help find the
cause of heart failure your health care
provider might also want to see how your
heart performs during exercise you might
need other tests to
your healthcare provider will work with
you to find the best treatment for your
symptoms and to keep your heart failure
from getting worse you may also need to
treat the cause of your heart failure
lifestyle changes are an important part
of treatment
your health care provider may recommend
a diet that is low in salt he or she may
also ask you to limit the amount of
fluid you drink you should also limit
alcohol consumption
losing weight
staying physically active
and quitting smoking can also help
you will likely get prescription
medications to treat your heart failure
one common type of medication is a
diuretic diuretics help to get rid of
excess fluid you may also be prescribed
an ACE inhibitor
this is a drug to reduce your blood
pressure
other drugs may help decrease how hard
your heart needs to work depending on
the cause of your heart failure your
healthcare provider may recommend a
procedure or surgery to help your heart
your provider can tell you more about
the best options for your heart failure
here are some things to remember
heart failure means that your heart
can't pump blood as it should
different health conditions can cause
heart failure you may need lifestyle
changes medications or procedures to
help treat your heart failure work
closely with your health care provider
to treat your heart failure together you
can help improve your symptoms and
quality of life